the drug company astrazeneca has paused
global trials
of its promising coronavirus vaccine
because of an illness
in one of its volunteers the company
says the move is part of a standard
process
to allow for the review of safety data
and it comes as millions of children
returned to school
amid alarming new numbers on the virus
the american academy of pediatrics says
covid 19 cases in kids
have now topped 500 000 in hard hit iowa
the issue of school safety is being
fought out in the courts
and our lead national correspondent
david begno is following all of this
david good morning to you
good morning yeah in the city of des
moines the school system went to a judge
and essentially said give us permission
not to follow the governor's executive
order and the court said no
and the school system essentially said
well we're not going to follow it anyway
at least for the time being
iowa's governor said unless you have a
test positivity rate of 15 percent
you need to offer in-person learning
half the time
in des moines it's roughly 10 percent
right now and that 15
bar experts say is really high when you
consider the fact that the white house
coronavirus task force has said
communities should not consider
reopening until they have a test
positivity rate below 10
and the world health organization says
it should be below five percent before
you think about reopening
here's the des moines school
superintendent i know our students need
to be in school
but not at the expense of their health
that's thomas a heart superintendent of
des moines public schools
he's responsible for roughly 32 000
students
a population he is so worried about that
he went against
iowa governor kim reynolds order to hold
at least
50 percent of classes in person so he
started school yesterday in his district
all online in defying state law and now
defying a court order
are you basically doing this because you
think it's
right i'm glad you asked that question
that's the only reason
that we're doing this just yesterday a
judge ruled that des moines public
schools
have to follow the rules set by the
state but ahart says he's continuing all
classes online until further notice
because even at fifty percent capacity
student safety he believes will be
compromised we've gone through with
literally with tape measures in every
single classroom assessing the capacity
in each of our buildings
we cannot do it and meet social
distancing requirements
we can open our schools back up we can
open our colleges back up
iowa's governor has said the state's
plan can be adaptable
while some schools are just opening
their doors colleges around the country
are still dealing with rises in covet
cases
our case counts are going up way
too fast officials at the university of
tennessee say drastic measures could be
on the horizon
now that more than two thousand people
are in isolation
and two weeks into the fall semester at
florida state university
more than 800 students have tested
positive for covid19
so next week the school will require
random testing
instead of relying on voluntary testing
you know here in the state of new york
the governor andrew cuomo has said
colleges now need to notify the state
if they surpass 100 covet cases on
campus and if they do they may have to
move toward
remote learning gail
david thank you